FIFA FIFA World Cup Brazil 2014 FIFA
Thank You World Cup Brazil with an S yes
we have an exclusive first look at the
World Cup video game that a FIFA is
releasing on Xbox 360 and PlayStation 3
and we play a lot of it in the office so
let's just dive straight into it because
we've got it we gotta check this game
and show the folks at home what's gonna
be in are you guys gonna start off with
the the Carnivale minigame not if but
when you mention like options that's
basically because this is based on FIFA
14 unlike current gen console it's not
the next-gen one it's not coming to Xbox
one or ps4 and but the main thing about
this is the amount of options that are
in it and we're just gonna play friendly
but first of all I just want to show
everyone like what's in it basically
since the main menu were very similar to
the Salafis game and World Cup Brazil
mode capturing a country returning the
road to World Cup is basically being
able to do like a full campaign
qualification story of qualifying is
like going back and rewriting matches
that happened in the real qualifying
which was in the old one-two story of
finals is gonna be updated during the
tournament with like oh man did you see
that crazy comeback the u.s. did against
Ghana which is gonna happen right now by
the way and they're gonna redo it to
some new skill games and the comeback is
not gonna be necessary no smack talk
here and wrote to Rio de Janeiro and
then there's online modes there's
somewhat there's a bunch of stuff in
here there's like the online modes have
like radio stations playing through it
with like podcast talking itself it's
really crazy but I favorite part about
soccer video games is modes there's so
many modes you alternate we both we can
we world both classic or alternate and
this is one of the interesting things is
that the you don't choose teams to
concurrently anymore you just kind of
choose them one by one
oh yeah why can't I can't choose so you
can't choose so you got away from me
you've never played this you can play
this no it means if I lose that's why oh
really yeah yes we're gonna replay this
is USA's first game in the tournament
right you guys are playing Ghana
that sounds right I think that's better
is it oh you're in North America stood
as North America as cocky cat
using me I like this I've already got
him off his game he's already confused
go to work and now you guys have a
competitive history here there's been
some FIFA tournaments in the office
there's often yelling emanating from one
corner of the floor yes
very intense FIFA competition here yes
there is and that's just because I
haven't joined in yet
no we will get less intense when I play
two matches to play I don't know in this
tournament we got another one going on
right now yeah that's true why playing
against I don't know it's a knockout
this time I want I just want to say for
everyone record I won the first
inaugural games Bosch World Cup
tournament with Ireland but only by
default because I got to the final with
two teams yeah Yahoo I realistically a
year ago I would win that so here's a
weird thing like some of the teams that
like there were this version this FIFA
World Cup game has every single team
that's in that's like in FIFA so like
even all these like crazy how many like
two I never tell them yeah yeah easily
and so like it's got gone and it for one
which is like they weren't actually even
in FIFA 14 last year like well really
yeah there's loads of international
teams that weren't in it ha and so this
is it sort of the the trimmings they put
on these World Cup games where it's all
about like the atmosphere the crowd like
the crowds have been updated or not
anywhere like as good as what's on the
next-gen games but they're definitely
way better than there's a lot of Bob the
builder's in the audience all these USA
foul these people are so you're playing
at Manaus Manaus is a city at the you
know right on the Amazon River you drop
this Brazil knowledge on us yeah yeah I
am
cuz that's literally all I have to
contribute to this hammock a PDA history
yes I'm telling you man where's the mini
game for take a boat upriver and try not
to get eaten by deadly fish this is a
soccer game okay foreign waters there's
enough excitement about the World Cup on
its own without having to add silly
minigames I actually get I do really
enjoy the World Cup that's the one time
of my life when I like it's like to
actually watch soccer game seek it out
at weird hours and does the US have like
the gun lock day once or twice by gonna
know
think I know last time they did I think
in 2006 they did as well it's pretty
impressive looking clint dempsey this is
the other thing they're watching it's a
capital o capital building sorry so like
they have so like they've got Trafalgar
Square for England you had like an Irish
Street for Ireland somewhere in Dublin's
yeah you're wondering if they had on in
the US there we go
yeah confirmation so when you see if
your team scores then they'd like we'll
come back how many how many countries
you think have that probably like five I
mean we didn't say we didn't see the gun
and yet we hear they're uh well they had
Ireland's and I was impressed by that
because Ireland aren't even in the World
Cup
like we didn't qualify but they still
had okay so I talked about it was
preliminary for that and I think I can't
skip this sorry we're taking our time I
think this is because it's our first
game and I didn't sign in with a profile
and so here we go alright dates
I'd be blue if you have any FIFA
questions which kind of mourners
personally is playing as the United
States I'm the United States only
natural all and I'm white and you're
blue you owe us any living his inner
African do a soccer kick run onto the
ball and so yeah if you have any
questions feel free to send them in yeah
yeah we're checking out the chat at
twitch.tv slash GameSpot and we're also
looking at the GameSpot comments and all
GameSpot situations like join us with
your words in terms of like how it plays
it's it's very similar to FIFA 14 like
the current gen ones or I don't even
know like three sig me in the last three
Andy I don't know which which way we're
going with yeah I mean what why would
they even change it well so they've done
some stuff they've like change like the
players do better right like it's
usually the same sort of stuff to ever
hear whether like fix the passing up a
bit tighten it up some of the like em
off the ball movement that was in FIFA
14 s been introduced but like it's kind
of hard to do a like polite comparison
because these are the best players in
the world so like every international
team is generally like being super good
yeah they usually pretty pretty decent
yeah that's offside Eric
yeah this is pretty much exactly the
same as old gents this is the first time
you've this is the first time yeah but
the the current end one that home feels
a lot better and there's a demo way for
this already as well as so people can
actually they are gonna show up now
because on my taxi ever toxic get it to
me give it straight to Tim Harris boy
Tim Howard responsible for perhaps my
favorite goal of the look at the other
wing yeah then we go perhaps my favorite
goal of the set African World Cup games
with just the wall you guys did against
was it was a North African team no you
so close the blue team online such a
good kick what was the game you guys
worried econ tyria Algeria that was like
the Donovan go yeah yeah we're Tim Eric
threw the ball out to the halfway line
fend like in the twitch chat echoes my
sentiments when he says sports harder
guys sports recording a sparkling more
sports
oh no get it I have to take a shot
alright do you know I'm going alter
attack because Magnus on live stream
control attack so you know it plays
similarly to FIFA games that are already
out and available for cheaper but that
they tend to like these these names as
not as full price products like is this
a forty fifty dollars if I get like you
know like I don't know the way I feel
about this is that if you're a fan of
soccer and like the amount of time you
get out of playing one of these four
games
oh no like you win you'll buy fifa 14
last year and then play it for you know
80 hours you sure and like the amend the
amount of modes that they try and add to
this like I feel like that's the reason
why you won't play it's like it's all
it's all the stuff that's gonna be
running concurrently with the tournament
because it'll it'll tie in tournament
stuff but the tournament is only about a
month long that's those weeks you know
like that actual time period you know
comes and goes so in terms of you know
how much time you're gonna spend playing
this is that also dependent on like
online play and so are you worth would
you worry about
he's like Soho when the last one came
out and I plays the the World Cup South
Africa won I really like that when that
one came as I played it for the majority
of during the tournament and then I
played it up until the release of the
next game okay and because you're kind
of still in like World Cup fever mode
because the regular seasons don't start
until like and you know mid end of
August anyway so like get your and then
I remember like spending a bit of time
at Christmas like going back and playing
that little bit as well this is
definitely more for the hardcore soccer
fan than this you know what actually I
don't think it is I read the oh no
Howard you the general fans priority
picked up FIFA 14 don't you think what
happens apparently I interviewed one of
the developers a couple of months ago
and what actually happens is that they
get more like Fairweather FIFA fans
buying this game than they will the
other ones just because in the
association with the World Cup yeah so
just any percentage of people who buy
this they reckon are people who don't
really play fee for that much and or
maybe buy a FIFA game every couple years
speaking of 750 show from GameSpot
wonders as someone who can't stand
watching or playing soccer that's what I
enjoy this did you get questions from
people who likes there's no let's just
go ahead and say no you're watching the
coverage of sports games that when
people are given a drag I disagree I
hate hates a strong word
I dislike baseball but I can play em Oh
music oh really yeah I think a lot of
land watch baseball I'd rather watch
paint dry no a lot of people who play
fifa actually don't enjoy soccer right I
think so yeah they get their kicks pun
intended out of out of just playing the
game because maybe they never played it
when they're a kid or something in that
I don't know maybe that's an American
thing in Europe it's certainly like hand
in hand with like everyone generally
like a lot of people watch soccer well
of course yeah well sorry but you can
see how all right the actual physical
act of getting out and running and
playing soccer could not appeal to
someone and then you know sitting and
watching a game at which they are a
passive participant is also not going to
thrill them but when you're sort of
taking a more active role you're
involved in it from a strictly like
gameplay perspective
you know I don't I don't think I would
enjoy running around and I think I would
pretty much abhor to run around and
shoot someone with a gun or watch actual
people shoot other people with guns but
I don't know I feel of first-person
shooter video game better you like Robin
with America these days I feel like FIFA
specifically like f1 games and like
stuff like that are for people who like
enjoy it on its it's it's not like
American football ice hockey where those
games it's you know you need there's
such an entrance like a requirement to
have equipment and other people to play
them like the beautiful thing about
about football is he all you need is a
bunch of folks in a kind of Ram fancy
things so I'm like confidence in your
degree of physical fitness and I think
that some degree more like you know
that's an American thing it's like and
also people don't always have people to
play with you know especially once you
get out of you know school days where
there are leagues and people just having
tons of spare time to play pickup games
I mean area so oh what a save oh you
could see it but I guess the wording of
the question was can't stand watching or
playing oh we still on this class get a
good question Chris check out the demo
good question yeah so what are the bars
moving under the players names well as
lamina stamina
the green is yeah that's it all right
when you press shoot there will be a bar
that increases the longer you hold it
but just the down all bars stamina Eric
we can't we can't miss this game in a
0-0 deal you score a soccer goal this is
like I know Ryan Mac is back there
thinking man you played these people
games for too long yeah a little ugh
watching Facebook yeah that's just a
boring sport it's always zero zero I
mean he be fair I don't find this boring
to watch I mean I you guys are
competitive players like there's clearly
some an amount of skill involved here
like this is entertaining
despite the questions I may be lovely
don't you here we go Oh like I'm
legitimately like going to be playing
this for the next Oh Danny have you
started calling it soccer already yeah
fair enough got to speak the locals are
the rosters accurate on smaller
countries like Haiti
riot yes and one of the interesting
things I saw were like like what they do
with all these games because this is
like a previous version what they do in
all of them is they they patch it like
off until the door goes so when the
final Tereus tilly what parentsí offside
free f you're kidding me
and what to do oh yeah all these games
that they patch them right up until
release so and they will they keep them
updated and keep them refreshed
yeah because they'll be players to get
injured you're like right before the
storm it's not sure unfortunately and
that's pretty much par for the course
with a lot of the top sports games these
days is keeping those rosters updated
yeah to the minute and the FIFA ones
like they're like blazing the trail are
not like FIFA games when a player gets
injured immediately in the game like
they have the updates like EA actually
do the stats tracking in the Premiership
like the ones that are used on
television EA is powering them so like
route of all that stuff is you know
three go AAA from GameSpot chat with a
question we would have loved to have you
chime in with at the very beginning can
you guys choose the stadium in recife
it's where I'm currently question from
yes so all of these stadiums are being
used in the World Cup are available just
not for this demo sorry Roger ego but I
just thanks for the question come on
Eric right if somebody doesn't score in
the next two minutes we just have to
score it on goal because I want to show
the celebrations okay all right so you
just score here score
you can do it I believe in you if you
don't I'm gonna make my goalie walk into
the goal you can do it the players I'm
still used to playing quick like I'm
sorry watch game you it's not your fault
it's that me and Eric got stage fright
and couldn't score in this game
it's you know performance anxiety is
common among many
I'm an international players men can't
score sex it's a problem oh well they
didn't show wait wait
why didn't show because it was an OG
yeah that maybe that's why cuz nobody
celebrates all you're watching is the
bitter shame of a man as let's go ahead
Danny goes back this is what I said no
don't let me score now you're gonna draw
one man out
I'm gonna come out yo ultra hey put it
up put it up give it a keeper don't
bring it out now what are you doing you
guys are playing us versus Bonnar right
now and that'll be it but what are your
favorite teams heading into the World
Cup is this an obvious answer on both
counts
well you're singling obviously right
that's something put me in that position
I'm us obviously what are you I'll
actually I'll be happy I look I'm an
underdog guy I support I'm Irish so and
it's gonna be a backhanded compliment to
America like I'm an underdog you know I
ride for sure and I go yeah you've got
the group of death we got the group at
that's pretty bad it's pretty bad Eric
Taylor thank you very much coming on
appreciate us